BC kemik kadro öğreneceğim coğraf
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük coğrafi
kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz. 39 günde
TS coğrafya ayrıntılı kampımızın bugün
geldik gençler 27. gününe. Bitti artık
laylom işin ciddiyetini kavrayın. Ciddi
konulara geldik çünkü. Ne demek? Artık
beşeri coğrafyaya geçiyoruz. Nüfusu
göreceğiz, bir soru geliyor her sene.
Ondan sonra bölgeleri göreceğiz, her
sene bir soru geliyor. Ondan sonra doğal
afeti göreceğiz. Her sene bir soru
geliyor. Yani resmen üç net sorumuz
bundan sonraki konularda. Buraya kadar
lay lomdu. Bundan sonraki konular ciddi
konular. Her sene soru getiren konular
dikkatli dinleyeceksin. Bundan önceki
konulara laylay lom dememe bakmayın.
Benim en çok sevdiğim konulardı bundan
önceki konular. Ben fiziki
coğrafyacıyım. Dağları, ovaları o o
şekilleri seviyorum. Fiziki coğrafya
dışarıdaki o doğal doğal kısmı seviyorum
ben. Ama asıl sorular bu beşeri kısımdan
gelecek. O yüzden bakın birçok kavram
öğrendik ya biz. O kavramların
bazılarını unuttum mu biliyor muyum
acaba ne oldu diye düşünme. Öğrendiğini
öğrendin. Yapabileceğini yapacaksın.
Bundan sonraki kısım senin için daha
değerli kısım. O yüzden hem de çok
yapılabilir yapılabilen bir kısım. Kolay
bir kısım yani. Öyle düşün. O yüzden
yeni bir motivasyonla yeni bir öğrenci
olarak tekrar yeniden başlıyoruz. Ben
kalemimi aldım. Hazırım. Sen de hazırsan
o zaman ne diyoruz? Yunus hocayla bir
defa öğren. Bir daha asla unutma. Zedua
ile eğitim her yerde.
Şimdi programımıza bakın. Buralarda bir
sürü konular gördük. Görüyor musunuz? 26
ayrı konu görmüşüz. Ama şundan sonra
göreceğimiz şu nüfus nerede? İşte nüfus
konuları şurada. Bunların hepsi nüfus.
Şurada ekonomik faaliyet. Yani şurada
bak bölgeler ve afetler. Şurada
göreceğimiz 8iz konudan 3 soru geliyor.
Gelecek. O yüzden dikkat etmeni
istiyorum. Bundan sonraki konular bizim
için çok değerli. Bugünkü konumuz
nüfusun özellikleri ve önemi olacak. Hem
de kısa kısa ben ayırdım, böldüm
bunları. Nüfusu tek videoda değil de
nüfusun önemi, nüfusun dağılı diye.
Güzel güzel ayırdım. Merak etme. Yine
soru çözümünü bu videoda yapacağız
diyorum. Artık ben hazırım. Sen de
hazırsan o zaman ne diyoruz? Hadi
başlayalım. Şimdi gençler bakın nüfusun
özellikleri ve önemi. Nüfus ne demek?
Belirli bir zamanda, sınırları tanımlı
bir bölgede yaşayan insan sayısıymış. Bu
tanımı bize sormaz ama demografiyi
sorabilir bize. Demografiyi de böyle
tanımını alın tanımıdır, tanımı şudur
diye sormaz. Nasıl sorar? Birçok kavram
vardı fiziki coğrafyada. Değil mi? O
kavramlar hep fiziki coğrafyadaydı. Bir
tane bize yabancı bir kavram lazım
beşeri coğrafyada. İşte o da demografi.
Çünkü beşeriden de araya sokması lazım.
O da demografi. Demografi ne demek?
Sınırları bir belirli bölgede bulunan
nüfusun yapısını, özelliklerini ve
değişimini inceleyen bilim. Yani nüfusu
inceliyormuş. Bu kadar yok tanımı orada
bak okudum. Çok önemli değil. Nüfus
gelecek aklına demografi geldiğinde.
Demokrasi demokrasiye benziyor. Bak
demografi demokrasiye benziyor.
Demokrasi insanlar yapar. Nüfus ha
nüfuslu olur. Demokrasi nüfustur
demokrasi. Tamam. Demografi bu önemli
bizim için. Demografi denildiğinde
aklına nüfus gelecek. Şimdi gençler
günümüzde nüfus sayımları yapılıyor,
değil mi? Nüfusun önemini konuşacağız
ama günümüzde yapılan nüfus sayımları
neden yapılıyor? Hangi amaçla? Bu da
bizim için değerli. Her bir madde bir
şık olabilir bunların. Çünkü nüfus
miktarını belirlemek için yapılıyor. Ne
kadar nüfus yaşıyoruz? Şuradaki şehirde
ne kadar? Buradaki şehirde ne kadar
nüfus? Miktarı belirliyoruz. Ülkenin
nüfus miktarını belirlemek için nüfusun
eğitim durumunu. Bunların hangisi lise
mezunu, kaç tanesi üniversite mezunu,
bunları belirliyoruz. Nüfusun ülkede
dağılışını belirliyoruz. Nüfus sayımları
sonrasında yani kimileri daha batıda
yoğunlaşmışken nüfusun seyrik olduğu
doğuyu mesela fark ediyoruz. Çünkü bunu
bildiğimiz zaman buna göre politika
üreteceğiz. Sektörel yapısındaki
değişimi ve hangi sektörde
çalıştıklarını öğreniyoruz insanların.
Tarım sektöründe mi, ulaşım sektöründe
mi, sanayi sektöründe mi, hizmet
sektöründe mi? Başım sektörü hizmette
zaten. Yaş gruplarına göre dağılışını
belirliyoruz. Yani 14 yaşına kadar kaç
çocuk var? 35 yaşında kaç tane insan
var? Kaç tane okula ihtiyacımız olur? Ne
kadar yaşlı nüfusumuz var? Ne kadar
hastane lazım gibi verileri öğreniyoruz
ki bunlara göre yatırım yapalım. Nüfus
hareketleri için insanların a İzmir'den
şu kadar insan göç etmiş. İstanbul'a bu
kadar insan göç etmiş. Bunları
öğreniyoruz nüfus sayımlarıyla. Kır kent
nüfusunu kırda yaşayanlar, kentte
yaşayanlar ve ne kadarı kadın, ne kadarı
erkek ülkemizde bütün bunları nüfus
sayımları sonrasında öğrenebiliyoruz
biz. Bu ama nasıl günümüzdeki nüfus
sayımlarının yapılma amacı bu. Geçmişte
de nüfus sayımları yapılıyordu.
Geçmişteki nüfus sayımları daha çok ne
kadar vergi toplayacağız ve askere ne
kadar insan gelecek bunlar için bunları
belirlemek için yapılıyordu. Bu kısımda
çok durmuyorum. Bizim asıl önemli olan
kısmımıza geleceğiz. Hala gelemedik
tabii. Şimdi gençler iki çeşit nüfus
sayımı var. De facto ve dejur. De facto
eskiden yapılıyordu. İnsanları
gidiyordunuz evlerine, sokağa çıkma
yasağı ilan ediliyordu ve gidip
evlerinde tek sayıyordu memurlar. Bundan
sonra tek tek işleniyordu bilgisayarlara
falan. Bunlar çok uzun zaman alıyordu.
Bu yüzden böyle 5 yılda, 10 yılda bilgi
yapılan sayımlardı. Geçmişte böyle
yapılıyordu sayımlar. Ama artık dejure
sayımı yapılıyor. Bizim ülkemizde de
bakın 2007'den sonra dejur yani otomatik
sistemden yapılıyor bunlar. internet
üzerinden sistem üzerinden otomatik
yapılıyor. Yani sizin ikamet kağınaza
göre yapılıyor bu sayımlar. Hepimiz bir
ikamet kağı kayıtlı olduğumuz için bir
basıyoruz tuşa her sene başında otomatik
olarak çıkıyor ortaya. Şöyle bakıyorum
arada mikrofona dokunup da yanlışlıkla
sesi kapatmayayım diye. Bir kere geldi
başımıza kampta biliyorsunuz. Biz de
2007'de buna geçtik. Şimdi bunları nasıl
kodluyoruz biz? Defacto. De facto bir
alışveriş mağazası değil mi? Reklama
girmez herhalde bu. Şimdi Defacto'ya
gidip yüz yüze alırsınız değil mi
giysilerinizi? Ha yüz yüze de facto
demekti. Dejur o zaman ikametgah
diyeceksin. De facto. Ha yüz yüze o
zaman diğeri ikametgah üzerinden
diyeceksin. Tamam gençler dünyada ilk
nüfus sayımları Çinliler, Sümerliler,
Mısırlılar yapmış. Osmanlı'da ilk nüfus
sayımını Mahmut yapıyor. Bakın 1831'de
yapmış. Bunlar o kadar önemli değil ama
yine söylemeden geçmeyeyim. Burada
değerli olan modern anlamda ilk nüfus
sayımlarını İskandinav ülkelerinde
yapılıyor. Yani şu anki anlamdaki nüfus
sayımları. İskandinav ülkelerinden
kastımız Norveç, İsveç, Danimarka
buralar. Bizim ülkemizde de ilk 1927'de
yapılmış. E tabii Cumhuriyet kurulduktan
sonra hemen yapılamamış. 1927'de
yapılabilmiş. Bunu söylemiştim. Vergiyi
belirlemek ve askere ne kadar kişiyi
alacağız? Bunu belirlemek için
yapılıyordu geçmişte sayımlar. Şimdi
gelelim asıl önemli olan kısma. Bu
zamana kadar yaptığımız layl lomdu.
Şimdi tamam nüfusu sayıyoruz. Bundan
bahsettiniz hocam da nüfusu neden
sayıyoruz? Ya da saydığımızda ortaya
çıkan bu özellikler bize nasıl nüfus
hakkında yorum yapmamızı sağlıyor? Bakın
bir tanesi nüfusun cinsiyet yapısıdır.
Nüfus sayımından sonra biz ülkelerin,
şehirlerin cinsiyet yapısını ortaya
çıkartırız. Bu bize ne sağlar? Bu bize
bir ülkenin bakın önemli olan nokta
burası gelişmiş ülke mi gelişmemiş ülke
mi yorumu yapmamızı sağlamaz. Özellikle
bu yorumları not alman lazım. Tamam.
Yani ben bir ülkeye baktığımda tabii ki
beynine not al. Ben bir ülkeye
baktığımda he bu ülkede %60 kadın var.
O zaman burası gelişmiş ülke. Bakın
böyle bir yorum yok. Tamam. Yani bir
ülkede kadınlar fazla, erkekler azsa ya
da erkekler fazla kadınlar azsa o ülkeye
gelişmiş ya da gelişmemiş yorumu
yapamazsın. Mantıklı değil ki. Tamam
böyle bir yorum yapamıyoruz biz. Genelde
gençler ülkelerdeki nüfuslar çok dengeli
olur. Bakın %49'la 45 kadın %50'ye böyle
birbirine çok yakındır. 50'ye 49'dur.
Böyle bir denge vardır dünyada. Nasıl
oluyor bilinmez ama böyle bir denge var.
Burada bir yorum yapabiliyoruz biz
burada. Ne? Şunun altını çizmeni
istiyorum senden. Göç veren yer. Göç
alan yer. Şimdi göç veren yerde kadınlar
daha fazla olabiliyor. Neden? Ben Van'da
görev yaparken mesela Van'daki
erkeklerin çoğu dışarıya çalışmaya
gidiyordu. İşte mevsimlik dönemlerde
farklı yerlere çalışmaya gidiyorlardı
ama genelde de inşaat alanında
çalışıyordu. Van'dakiler inşaatçıydılar.
E inşaata kim gidecek? Erkek gidecek.
Kadınlar geride kalacak. Göç veren
yerlerde kadın nüfusu daha fazla
olabiliyor. Güç alan yerlerde de mesela
İstanbul'a insanlar çalışmaya geliyor.
Genelde de erkekler çalışmaya geliyor.
Göç alan yerde de erkek nüfusu fazla
olabiliyor. Böyle bir yorum
yapabiliyoruz buradan. Tamam. Ama
gelişmiş mi gelişmemiş mi yorumu
yapamıyoruz. Şurası çok değerli.
Ortalama yaşam süresi. Şimdi geliyoruz
buna. Ortalama yaşam süresini
belirlediğimizde bir ülkenin o ülkeye
gelişmiş mi gelişmemiş mi diye
biliyoruz. Ortalama yaşam süresi bir
ülkede uzunsa yani insanlar ne demek bu?
Yorumla bunu. İnsanlar 60 yaşına kadar
yaşayabiliyorlarmış. 60 yaş da az oldu
ya. 80 yaşına kadar yaşayabiliyorlarmış
bir ülkede. Bir ülkede de 50 yaşına
kadar ortalama yaşam süresi varmış.
Nasıl bir yorum yaparsın? Buradaki
yorumları yapmak değerli. Dikkatli
dininden. İnsanlar 80 yaşına kadar
yaşıyorsa he ortalama yaşam uzun. O
zaman burada sağlık imkanları fazla.
İnsanlar iyi besleniyorlar. O zaman
burası gelişmiştir dersin. Bak 80 yaş.
Ama bir ülkede insanlar ortalama yaşam
süresi 50 ise 40 bu ülke gelişmemiş
ülkedir dersin. Bakın Japonya'da genel
insanlar 80 yaş 84'e kadar yaşıyormuş.
Bak İsviçre'de 83, İspanya'da 83 ama
şuraya bak. Az gelişmiş ülkelere
Somali'de 56. Çatta 59'unda insanlar
ölüyormuş. Bu bir tane iki tane insandan
bahsetmiyoruz. Ortalama ortalama
Japonya'da insanlar ortalaması 84'e
kadar yaşıyormuş. Tabii ki burada 90 100
yaşında demek ki çok insan var ki
ortalamaya vurunca 84'te oluyor. Demek
ki gelişmiş ülkelerde ortalama yaşam
süresi uzun, gelişmemiş ülkelerde kısa.
Ben şimdi gelişmemiş diyorum ama bu
tabir yanlış. Az gelişmiş ülkeler demek
daha doğru. Bu alışkanlıktan bunu böyle
diyoruz. Daha kolay da anlaşılabildiği
için. Diğeri nüfusun yaş gruplarına
dağılı. Burası çok değerli. Bak bu
yaptığım yorumların her biri sorularda
senin karşına çıkacak yorumlar. O yüzden
her bir cümlemi burada dikkatli
dinliyorsun. Nüfusun yaş gruplarına
dağılışın ne demek? Yani şu 014 yaş
arasına biz çocuk nüfusu diyoruz. 1564
yaş arasına yetişkin. Bunlar çalışan
nüfus daha çok. Aynı zamanda çocuk
nüfusu da bağımlı bir nüfus. Çalışmadığı
için bağımlılar. Evet. 65 yaşın üstüne
de yaşlı nüfus diyoruz. Bunlar da yine
çocuklar gibi bağımlı nüfus. Şimdi asıl
yoruma geliyoruz. Bak birçok soruda bu
soru soruluyor. Ben sen hiçbir bilgiye
sahip değilmişsin gibi anlatıyorum sana.
Merak etme. Eğer ki bir ülkede çocuk
bağımlı nüfus fazlaysa o ülke nasıldır?
Bir düşün. Çocuklar çok fazlaymış. He.
İnsanlar sekiz tane çocuk yapıyormuş.
Bak çok fazla çocuk varmış. Çocuk
bağımlı fazlaymış. O zaman burada eğitim
seviyesi düşüktür. Çok fazla çocuk
yapılıyordur. Yani burası gelişmemiş bir
ülke demek. Bak bunun mantığını oturtman
lazım. Tamam mı? Diğeri 65 yaş bağımlı
nüfusu çok fazlaymış. Böyle bir yorum
gördüm. Ne diyeceksin? He diyeceksin
hocam insanlar çok yaşlanmış. Çok yaşlı
bir ülke burası. Gençler bir ülke çok
yaşlıysa gelişmiş bir ülkedir. Almanya
gibi ülkelerden bunu düşünün. Ya da
Japonya'dan mesela Japonya gibi
ülkelerde çocuk yapılmıyor. Yıllardır bu
böyle. Bütün o alttaki nüfusta
yaşlanmış, yaşlanmış. Artık öyle bir
hale gelmiş. Ülke yaşlanmış. Bakın,
Japonya gibi ülkelerde yaşlı nüfus çok
fazladır. Çocuk yoktur. Ha, gelişmiş
ülkelerde yaşlılar fazla diyeceksin.
Çocuklar azdır. Bu yorumu yapıyorsan
artık olay senin için çok daha basit.
Tamam. Bizim için en değerli yorum
buydu. Okur yazar oranı kısmını
yorumlamak senin için kolay. E tabii
gelişmiş Almanya gibi gelişmiş ülkelerde
okuryazar oranı yüksektir. Afganistan
gibi gelişmemiş ülkelerde okur yaazar
oranı düşük. Bak %28 çok düşük. Doğum ve
ölüm oranları. Bu da bu yorum da çok
değerli. Bunu hemen somutlayacağız. Ben
genelde böyle şeyleri yorumlarken hep
somutlarım ve her zaman Almanya garbimle
şey Almanya niye garibim olsun ona iyi
şeyler söylüyoruz. Somali garibimi
veririm. Somali garibim. Gençler bakın
doğum oranları Almanya gibi ülkelerde
azdır düşüktür. Neden? Çünkü nüfus orada
öyle hızlı artmıyor. Çocuk yapmıyorlar
ama Somali gibi ülkelerde doğum oranları
fazladır. Bu yorumu yapacaksın. Çünkü
Somali'de insanlara eğitimsiz 8 tane 10
tane çocuk yapıyorlar. Ölüm oranları
nasıl peki? Almanya gibi ülkelerde ölüm
oranları azdır. Yaşlı nüfus fazla. Evet.
Ama ölümler öyle fazla değil. Sadece
bunun yaşlıdan kaynaklanmıyor. Bir sürü
şeylerden ölüm kaynaklanıyor. Doğumda
ölüm var. Bunun kazalarda ölüm var.
Sağlıktan kaynaklanan, sağlıksızlıktan
kaynaklanan, beslenememekten kaynaklanan
ölümler var. Somali gibi ülkelerde
ölümler fazladır. Almanya gibi ülkelerde
ölüm oranları düşüür. Tamam. Bunu
unutmuyorsunuz. Bunu da
ezberlemiyorsunuz. Ne yaptık? Mantıken
çıkarttık. Aktif nüfusun sektörlere
dağılımı yine en değerli yorumlardan bir
tanesi. Ya hocam her birine en değerli
diyorsunuz. Evet. Çünkü asıl soru
buradan geliyor bize. Aktif nüfusun
şuraya bakın şimdi. Birincil ekonomik
sektör tarımdır gençler. Tamam mı?
İkincil ekonomik sektör sanayidir.
Üçüncü ekonomik sektör hizmettir. Bu bu
çok değerli. Bak buraya dikkat et. Şimdi
biz bunu yine ayrıca göreceğiz ama
burada da gör. Birincil insanlar ilk
önce insan tarihinde tarım sektöründe
çalışmışlar değil mi? Sonra sanayi
sektörü gelmiş. Sanayi çıkmış. Sonra
hizmet gelmiş. Yani 1 2 3 denildiğinde
sana önce tarım, sonra sanayi, sonra
hizmet diyeceksin. Tarım sektöründe
çalışıyorsa bir ülkede insanlar o ülke
gelişmemiştir. Çünkü tarım sektöründe
gençler ne kadar para kazanabilirsiniz
ki? Zaten tarım sektöründe çalışan bu
insanlar kendi karınlarını doyurmak için
yapıyorlar. Mesela bakın tarım sektörü
%66. Şu ülkede tarımda çalışan insanlar
%66. Şurada bu tarım. Bak bu ne demek?
Ha burası Somali demek. İşte Somali'de
insanların %66'sı böyle tarımda çalışır.
Ülkede para kazanamaz insanlar da
karnını doyurmak için yaparlar bunu. Ama
bakın gelişmiş ülkelerde Almanya gibi
ülkelerde %78'i
hizmette çalışır. O zaman sen şu yorumu
not alıyorsun. Demek ki tarımda çalışan
bir ülke gelişmemiştir. Yani
çalışanlarının çoğu tarım sektöründe
çalışıyorsa gelişmemiştir. Ama
çalışanlarının çoğu hizmet sektöründe
çalışıyorsa o zaman bu ülke gelişmiş
ülkedir. Yorumu yapıyorsun. Anlaştık mı
burada? Şimdi diğeri şehir kır nüfusu.
Bir ülkenin şehir ve kır nüfusuna
bakarak o ülkenin gelişmiş mi gelişmemiş
mi olduğunu söyleyebiliyoruz. Bir ülkede
insanlar şehirde yaşıyorsa ağırlıklı
olarak o ülke gelişmiştir. Kırda
yaşıyorsa gelişmemiştir. Bakın İsveç
gelişmiş bir ülke. İnsanların %86'sı
şehirde yaşıyor. %14'ü kırda. Çada bakın
gelişmemiş bir ülke. %70'i kırda
yaşıyor. %23'ü şehirde yaşıyor. Anlaştık
mı? Dünyada bu oran bakın %54'e 46'ymış.
Buradaki mantığı anladık mı? Tamam.
Şimdi geliyoruz nüfus artışına. Şimdiye
kadar ne yaptık? Bir ülkenin kadın erkek
nüfusuna, şehir kırı nüfusuna, çalışan
işte çalışmayan yaş gruplarına, okur
yazar oranlarına bakarak ülkeler
hakkında nasıl bir yorum
yapabileceğimizi öğrendik. Bu yorumları
ezberlemiyorsun. Sana sorulduğunda yorum
yapabilmek değerli. Şimdi geldik nüfus
artışına. Nüfus artışını gençler ikiye
ayırıyoruz biz. Bunlardan bir tanesi
doğal nüfus artışı, diğeri gerçek nüfus
artışı. Burası değerli. Bunlar
arasındaki ayrımı bilmen lazım. Normalde
doğal olarak insanlar nasıl çoğalır,
nasıl artar? Doğumlar olur. Değil mi? 5
kişinin doğduğunu varsayalım. Doğumlar
olur, nüfus artar. Ama bir de bunun
ölümleri vardır. Doğumlar olduğu kadar
ölümler de oluyor. İki tane kişinin de
öldüğünü varsayalım. Bak nüfus şu an
arttı. Gördünüz mü? Kaç kişi arttı? 3
kişi arttı. İşte biz buna doğal nüfus
artışı diyoruz. Bunun kodlaması ne?
Doğal. Doğum. Doğumlarla olan nüfus
artışı. Bu doğumlar ve ölümlerle olan
nüfus artışı. Anladık mı buradaki
mantığı kodlamasını? Diğeri ne? Gerçek
nüfus artışı. Gerçekte olan nüfus
artışı. Şimdi bir ülkede 5 kişi doğmuş,
iki kişi ölmüş. Nüfusun 3 kişi artması
gerekiyor. Verilere bir bakıyoruz 4 kişi
artmış. Yanlış hareket yaptım ya. 5 kişi
ya. 4 y. Şöyle bak. 4 kişi artmış. E
hocam 3 kişi artması lazımdı. İki kişi
ölmüştü. E bu bir kişi ne? Ha demek ki o
bir kişi göçle gelmiş. İşte gençler
gerçek nüfus artışı işin içerisinde
doğumlar ve ölümlerin yanında gerçek
göç. Göç var orada. göçlerin de olduğu
nüfus artışıdır. İşin içerisine görçek
göçler de giriyor burada. Tamam mı?
Nasıl göçler giriyormuş? Ya nüfusu
azalmıştır ya da artmıştır. Doğumların
dışında işin içinde gerçek de göçler de
var demek. Doğal nüfus artışı doğumlar
ve ölümler arasında oluyor. Gerçek nüfus
artışı ha işin içerisine göçler de
giriyor. Gerçek göç. Tamam mıyız?
Dünyada gençlerin nüfus artış hızı en
fazla Afrika ülkelerinde. Çünkü Afrika
ülkeleri az gelişmiş ülkeler ve
gerçekten hiç durmadan çocuk yapıyorlar.
Nüfus artış hızı burada çok fazla. Doğal
nüfus artış hızı en fazla burada. Şuraya
bakın. Rusya, Küba gibi ülkeler, Japonya
nüfusu gençler eksi yazıyor. Bu çok
böyle görülebilen bir olay değil. Yani 5
kişi doğmuş, 6 kişi ölmüş. Nüfus eksi
yazıyor. Bu böyle çok nadir ülkelerde
görülüyor. Nüfusun eksi yazdığı ülkeler
bunlar. Bunun nedeni ne? Rusya gibi
ülkelerde, Japonya gibi ülkelerde
nüfusun eksi yazmasının nedeni doğum
oranları düşük. Çünkü bu ülkelerde
ülkelerde yaşlı nüfus fazla. Doğum da
olmayınca eksi yazıyor. Bir durum daha
var eksi yazma kısmında. Bu istisnai bir
durum ve çok değerli bir durum. Ben
olsam soru olarak bunu sorardım. Bak
nüfusun eksi yazdığı hem de ölümüne eksi
yazdığı binde -20 binde -40. Bunu hiç
ülkelerde göremezsiniz. Böyle bir şey
yok. Bu doğumlar ve ölümlerle alakalı
bir şey değildir. İşte bu Venezuela,
Suriye gibi ülkelerde mülteci göçüyle
milyonlarca insan başka ülkelere göç
ediyor. Venezuela'da da böyledir
gençler. Suriye'de bunu biliyorsun.
Suriye'yi ama Venezuela'yı
bilmiyorsunuz. Venezuela Amerika'nın
ambargosu var. Dünyanın petrolüne sahip.
Dünyada birinci sırada petrolde ama
ambargo yiyor. İnsanlar açlıktan
kırılıyor. Ülkeden kaçıyorlar. Dünyada
en fazla mülteci sorunu Suriye'de
Venezuela'da vardır. Milyonlarca kişi
dışarıda yaşar. Bu da nüfusunu eksi
yazdırır. Tamam. Bunu unutmayın. Şimdi
nüfusu arttıran faktörleri yorumlamayı
öğreneceksin. Nüfus artışını öğrendik
ya. Nüfusu arttıran faktörler var. Bu
işte sınav sorusu. Nüfus nasıl artar?
Yorumla nüfus nasıl artar? Bakalım.
Doğum oranları fazla olursa Evet. 8 tane
çocuk olursa artar. Doğru. Hemen yanına
arttı. Bunları bu maddeleri ezberleme.
Allah'ım bak bu maddeleri bilmenin
hiçbir anlamı yok sana. Bunları oturup
yazmanın yani yazarak böyle bunları
ezberleyeyim diye uğraşmanın hiçbir
anlamı yok. Yazma. Sadece yorumlamayı
öğren. Bak doğumları artarsa e çocuk
doğuyor. O zaman nüfus artar. Bitti. Bu
kadar geç. Bitti. Sen artık bunu
yorumlarsın. Bak sağlık hizmetleri
gelişirse yorumlamayı öğren. Sağlık
hizmetleri gelişirse insanlar sağlıklı
olur. Ameliyatlarla kurtulurlar.
İlaçlarla kurtulurlar. Ölmezler. Ha
insanlar ölmezse nüfus artı. Bak bu
yorumu öğrendin mi şimdi? Tamam. Diğer
ülkelerin nüfusu arttırıcı politikaları
nüfusu arttırır. Çünkü ülkeler nüfusu
arttırmaya çalışıyorlar. Mesela bizim
ülkemizde nüfusu arttırmaya çalışıyor. E
bu da teşvik yapıyor. Para desteği
verebiliyor. Ne bileyim hatta son
zamanda ne dediler? Memur yapacağız. Ü
tane çocuğu olan kadınları memur
yapacağız dediler. Bak al sana teşvik.
Üç tane çocuk yapar herkes. Ha doğru mu
bu bilgi? Değil mi? Yaparlar mı
yapmazlar mı bilmiyorum. Böyle bir haber
okumuştum. Bu nüfusu arttırıcı politika.
Demek ki nüfusu arttırmada etkili oluyor
muymuş? Oluyormuş. İş imkanlarının
artması da nüfusu arttırıyor gençler. İş
imkanları olduğunda, ekonomi iyi
olduğunda insanlar çoğalma
eğilimindedir. Bu ekonomiyle
bağlantılıdır. İnsanların parası
olduğunda, "Ya bakarım ben çocuğuma
imkan da sunuyorum. Ne kadar güzel işte
para olunca çocuk yapılır." Ben mesela
tam olarak böyle düşünebiliyorum. Ya
şükürler olsun param var. Çocuğumun
yarın geleceğini de geleceği içinde ona
da yatırım yapabileceğim. Yani çocuğumun
eğitimine yatırım yapabileceğim, onun
imkan, ona imkanlar sunabileceğim param
var. Ya çocuk olsa da benim için sorun
değil yani. İsterim, severim. Ama çocuk
param olmasa korkarım. Çocuk yapmaktan
çekinirim, geri dururum. O yüzden
ekonomi, iş imkanları, nüfusu, iş
imkanları iyiyse nüfusun artması için
önemli bir şey bu. Gelenekler.
Gelenekler de nüfusu arttırıyor. Nasıl?
Doğuyoruz, sonra askere gidiyoruz,
okuyoruz vesaire. Ama en sonunda herkes
bizden ne bekliyor? Ailemiz, çevremiz,
toplum, çocuk bekliyor. Çocuk
yapılmadığında kınanıyoruz. Bu iş böyle.
Bu bilinçli yapılan bir şey değil. Bizim
geleneklerimizde bilinçaltımızda var
gençler. Böyle yaşıyoruz. Gelenekler
işte bu yüzden nüfusu arttırıyor. Dinler
de nüfusu arttırmaya yönelik söylemlerde
bulunur. Çoğalmayı teşvik eder. Göçler
ama nasıl gelen göçler? Eğer ülkeye
nüfus göç geliyorsa mesela bir sürü
Suriyeli mülteci geldi bizim ülkemize.
Nüfusumuzu arttırdı. Bunlar nüfusu
arttırmaya yönelik arttıran maddelerdi.
Buradaki mantığı anladık mı? Şimdi
nüfusu azaltanlara bakalım. Savaşlar
nüfusu azaltır değil mi? doğal afetler
nüfusu azaltabilir. Çok ciddi depremler
yaşandığında, tsunamiler yaşandığında,
kasırgalar yaşandığında birçok insan
hayatını kaybedebiliyor. Nüfus
azalabiliyor. Bakın şu değerli, bunlar
kolay. Bunları sen de yorumlarsın zaten.
Şu değerli yorum, kadının iş hayatına
atılması. Kadınlar işe giderse nüfus
azalıyor. Nüfus artış hızımız azalıyor.
Çünkü işe, işe giden kadınlar, işe
gitmek zorunda olan kadınlar çocuk
yapamıyorlar. Normalde 4 tane be tane
çocuk yapmayı isteyen bir kadın iş
hayatına gittiğinde bir taneyi zorla
yapıyor. Hadi ikinciyi anca ikinciyi
yapabiliyor. Demek ki kadınlar işe
başlarsa kadınların iş hayatına atılması
nüfus artış hızının azalmasına neden
oluyor. Giden göçler artı koyuyorum ya.
Giden göç dışarı gidiyor. E bak ha bak
şehirden şehre giden göçler değil.
Bursa'dan İstanbul'a giden göç nüfusta
azalma ya da artma yapmaz. Ama Bursa'dan
Almanya'ya giden göç azaltır nüfusumuzu.
Değil mi? Eğitim seviyesinin artması
gençler. Eğitim seviyesi arttıkça çocuk
yapma oranı düşüyor. Bu böyledir.
Dünyada insanlar eğitimli hale
geldiklerinde ya ben bu çocuğa bakabilir
miyim? Maddi olarak bakıp bakmamanın
dışında duygusal olarak da bakabilecek
miyim noktasında çok düşünüyor insanlar.
Ya da eğitim seviyesi artınca insanlar
biraz daha bencilleşebiliyorlar.
Kendilerini de yani kendi hayatını bu
kötü anlamda söylemiyorum bunu ya kendi
hayatında yaşamak isteyebiliyor. Böyle
olunca eğitim seviyesinin artması nüfusu
nüfus artış hızımızı düşürüyor gençler.
Eğitim seviyesi artan toplumlarda çocuk
yapılma oranı düşüyor. Diğeri ülkelerin
izlediği nüfus azaltıcı politikalar.
Bazı ülkelerde nüfusunu azaltmaya
yönelik politikaları izliyor. Bir tane
çocuk yapacaksın diyor. İki tanesine
izin vermiyorum diyor. Ya da çok çocuk
yaparsan çok vergi alırım senden diyor.
Ve nüfusu azaltıcı yönde hamleler
yapıyor. Şimdi nüfus artış hızının fazla
olmasının ya da az olmasının azalmasının
olumlu olumsuz sonuçları oluyor. Bunları
yorumlayacağız. Şimdi seninle ne
yorumlamayı öğrendik? Bu maddelerin
hiçbir tanesini ezberlemedin. Ne yaptın?
Yorumladın sana. Şimdi ben kadın iş
hayatına atılırsa nüfus artış hızı nasıl
olur diye sorduğumda kadın işe giderse
çocuk yapamaz. Nüfus artış hızımız
azalır. Bu yorumu yaptın mı? Bitti.
Tamam. Hiç korkma. O maddelere bir daha
bakmaya hiç gerek yok. Şimdi de nüfus
artış hızının fazla olmasının çok nüfus
artıyor. Olumlu ve olumsuz sonuçları
oluyor. Bunları yorumlamayı
öğreneceksin. Şimdi olumlu sonucu olur
mu? Nüfus çok artarsa olur. Mesela
nüfusumuzun ülkemizde çok arttığını
düşünelim. O zaman mal ve hizmetlere
talep artar. Bu olumlu bir şey midir?
Evet. Şimdi mal ve hizmetlere talep
artarsa gençler o zaman sen ülkede vergi
alırsın. Devlet açısından düşünün bunu.
Sürekli bir mal ve hizmetlere talep var.
Üretim var. Üretim hızlıca tükeniyor.
Onların hepsinden vergi alıyor devlet.
Yani bir ekonomide, ticarette para
akıyor. Paranın aktığı yer zenginlik
olur. O yüzden mal ve hizmetlere talep
artar, vergi gelirleri artar, üretim
artar. Çok fazla nüfus olursa
Suriyelilerin ülkemizde olmasının yani
nüfusun fazla olmasının getirdiği böyle
avantajlar var. Tabii vergi alma
noktasında ne kadar alabiliyor devlet? O
bir soru işareti ama sonuçta mal ve
hizmetlere bir talep geldi Suriyelilerin
gelmesiyle beraber ve bu da üretimin
artmasını sağladı ülkemizde ve iş gücü
maliyetleri azalır. Mesela ülkemize
Suriyeliler geldiğinde çalıştılar.
Birçok yerde çalıştılar. İş gücü
maliyeti ne oldu? Azaldı. İnsanlar
normalde işte günlüğü tamamen afaki
söylüyorum. 1.000 liraya çalışıyorsa
Suriyelileri 500 liraya
çalıştırabildiler. Bak iyi bir şey. E
hocam bu iyi bir şey değil ki. kötü bir
şey. Hayır, bunu kendi açından düşünme.
Bu veriler devlet açısında, bu olumlu
bir şey. İş gücü maliyetinin azalması
olumlu bir şey devlet için. Senin için
kötü olabilir, benim için kötü olabilir.
Devlet için olumlu bir şey. Bunu unutma.
Buna yıldız at. İş gücü maliyetlerinin
azalması olumlu bir şeydir. Peki
nüfusumuzun fazla olması, somutlayalım.
Suriyelilerin ülkeye gelmesinin olumsuz
sonuçları oldu mu? Oldu. Kişi başına
düşen milli gelir azaldı. Tabii ki onlar
resmi olarak görünmediği için şu an
verilerde yok ama az bir kısmı yine
veriler içerisinde olsa da kişi başına
düşen milli gelir azalıyor. Kişi başına
düşen milli gelir kaç? En son 15.000
dolar olarak mı açıklanmıştı ya? Bir
bakar mısınız? Yorumlara yazın. Eğitim
sağlık imkanları yetersiz kalıyor.
Mesela hastanelere gittiğinizde bunu
görebiliyorsunuz. Bir kalabalık durum
olabiliyor. Ulaşamayabiliyorsunuz sağlık
imkanlarına. Hatta randevu almaya
kalkıyorsunuz alamıyorsunuz bile. Neden?
Nüfus fazla çünkü. Bak olumsuz bir
sonuç. E ne oldu sonuç? İşsizlik artı.
Evet. Nüfus fazla olunca artık iş
bulamıyoruz. Olumsuz bir sonuç. Ülke
tasarruf edemez. Nüfus fazla olduğu için
sürekli hastane, sürekli yatırım yapması
gerekiyor. Sürekli memur alması
gerekiyor. Bak tasarruf yapamıyor
devlet. Suç oranları arttı. Bunu net bir
şekilde görüyoruz değil mi? Nerede
çokluk, orada kötülük. Nüfus fazla
olduğunda suç oranları da artıyor. Çevre
sorunları artar. Çevrede bir baksanıza
kalabalık olan yerlerde çevre gerçekten
çok kötü durumda. Doğal kaynaklar.
Ülkemizin doğal kaynakları hızla
tükeniyor. Bu da olumsuz bir sonuç.
Demografik yatırımlar artıyor. Bu olumlu
bir şey gibi görünüyor. Ama demografik
yatırım demek nüfusa yatırım yapmak
demek. Okul hastane yapmak anlamına
geliyor. Bu olumsuz bir şeydir gençler.
Devletin parası gidiyor, tasarrufları
gidiyor. Yani okul hastane yapmak
zorunda kalıyor sürekli. Bu olumsuz.
Peki hocam nüfus artış hızının az
olmasının nüfus az artıyormuş.
Olumlu sonuçları neler? E az nüfus varsa
kişi başına daha çok para düşer. Düşer.
Sağlık, eğitim kalitesi artar. az nüfusa
çok rahatlıkla sağlık
ulaştırabilirsiniz. Bak bu olumlu bir
şey. Yatırımlar artar. Çok para var
devlette. Sürekli yatırım yapabilir.
Bakın nüfusun, nüfus artış hızının az
olmasının olumlu sonuçları az. Dikkat
ettiniz mi? Şimdi burada Türkiye'nin
politikasını neyse onu Türkiye'de
konuşuruz. Değerli bir şey. Dünyada
nüfus sorunu yaşanıyor gençler. Bakın
nüfusun az olmasının olumlu sonuçları
çok az. Sağlığı iyi alırsın. Evet.
Eğitimi iyi alırsın. Evet. Yatırımlar
art. Kişi başına düşen milli gelir fazla
olur. Evet. Ama olumsuz sonuçlarına
bakalım. Yaşlı nüfusu artar ülkede.
Emekli paraları artık devlet ödeyemez
hale gelir. Nüfus hareketliliğini
kaybeder. Çok tehlikelidir. Mal ve
hizmetlere talep azalır. Üretim azalır.
Yaşlı nüfus giderek artar. Burada iki
kere yazılmış bu. Bunu düzeltelim. Ülke
göç almak zorunda kalır. Ve ülke göç
almak zorunda kalırsa ülke kendi
kültürünü, kendi ülkesini kaybetmeye
başlar. Ne demek? Farklılaşırsın.
Almanya mesela sürekli dışarıdan işçi
göçü almak zorunda kaldı. Sonra ne oldu?
Almanya'nın içerisinde farklı farklı
ülkelerden farklı farklı grupların
egemen olduğu farklı farklı yapılar
ortaya çıkıyor. Bu sefer Almanlar kendi
kültürlerini yaşayamaz hale bile
geliyorlar. Dışarıdan gelen o insanlar
Almanlara kendi kültürlerini dikte
edebilir hale bile geliyor. Evet. Bunlar
da olumlu sonuçlardı. Olumsuz
sonuçlardı. Şu iş gücü noktasında ben
sizi uyarmıştım. Dikkat edin diye.
Ülkeler için iyi bir şeydir diye dinleri
de anlatmıştım. Geleneklerin de nasıl
etkili olduğunu anlatmıştım. Şimdi
gelelim nüfusu ikiye katlama süresine
gençler. Nüfus 2'ye katlama süresi şu
demek. Mesela bir ülkenin nüfusu var 50.
Bunu 100'e katlayacak. Bak nüfusu 2'ye
katlayacak. Şimdi nüfusu 50 olan bir
ülke düşünelim. Nüfusunu 100'e 2'ye
katlaması çok kısa bir zamanda
gerçekleşiyormuş. Yani şu cümleyi kurdu
bize soruda. Nüfusu 2'ye katlaması
kısadır. Bak nüfusu 50, nüfusu 100'e
2'ye katlıyoruz. Kısa bir sürede
katlıyoruz. Bu hangi ülkeler? Gelişmiş
ülkeler mi, gelişmemiş ülkeler mi? Hemen
ikiye katladık nüfusu. Gelişmemiş
ülkeler. Somali gibi ülkelerde çocuk
doğumları falan çok yüksek olduğu için
nüfus ikiye katlama süresi de kısa
oluyor. Hemen ikiye katlıyor. Almanya'yı
yapalım. Almanya'nın 50 milyon olduğunu
varsayalım. Almanya'nın 100 milyona
çıkması çok uzun yıllarda olur. Neden?
Çünkü Almanya'da çocuk doğumları az.
Nüfusu ikiye katlama süresi Almanya'da
nasıl? Almanya'da uzun. Ha demek ki
nüfusu ikiye katlama süresinin uzun
olduğu ülkeler gelişmiş ülkelerdir
diyeceksin. Evet şimdi gelelim soru
çözümüne. Dünya nüfusunun tarihsel
değişimi bir sonraki videonun konusu.
Geçelim soru çözümüne. Sayfa 117 test
57. Demografik, sosyal ve ekonomik
verilerin toplanması, değerlendirilmesi
ve analiz edilmesine nüfus sayımı denir.
Nüfus sayımı ile ilgili özelliklerden
hangileri belirlenebilmektedir? Nüfus
sayımı yaptığımızda cinsiyetini
öğreniriz, değil mi? Kadın erkekleri
nüfusun yaş durumunu 15 yaş, 65 yaş
bunları öğreniriz. Sayımda nüfusun
eğitim durumunu da lise mi, üniversite
mezunu mu bunlar bunu da öğreniriz. Yani
cevabımız E. Bunların hepsi nüfus
sayımında ortaya çıkar. Geçelim diğer
soruya. Aşağıda haritada bazı ülkeler
numaral olarak gösterilmiştir. Bu
ülkelerin hangisinde okur yazar oranının
en fazla olduğu söylenebilir? Gelişmiş
ülke arayacağız. Meksika'da o kadar
fazla değildir okuryazar oranı.
Türkiye'de o kadar fazla değildir.
Aslında fazladır. %99'larda okuryazar
oranı. Ama bize ne diyor? en fazla olanı
soruyor. Bakın burada Almanya var.
Almanya mı daha fazla? Hindistan mı, Çin
mi, Türkiye mi, Meksika mı? E tabii ki
bunlar arasında en gelişmiş olanı
Almanya. O zaman en fazla okur yazar
oranına sahip olan da Almanya. Geçelim
diğer soruya. Geçmişten günümüze farklı
şekillerde de olsa nüfus sayımları
yapılmıştır. Bu nüfus sayımları ile
ilgili ifadelerden hangisi yanlıştır?
İlk sayımlar Çin, Mısır. Evet, Çin,
Mısır bu civarlarda yapılmıştı ilk
sayımlar. Daha sonraki dönemlerde
Mezopotamya'da nüfus sayımları
yapılmıştır. Bu bilgi de doğru gençler.
Mezopotamya'da da nüfus sayımları
yapıldı. Modern anlamda ilk sayımlar 18.
yüzyılda İskandinav ülkelerinde
Danimarka, İsveç oralardaydı. Doğru. İlk
periyodik sayımlar Avustralya'da
yapılmıştır. Yanlış. İlk periyodik nüfus
sayımları gençler İsveç'te zaten modern
anlamda ilk sayım dediğimizde bu
periyodik sayım anlamına geliyor. İsveç,
Danimarka, İskandinav ülkelerinde
Avustralya'da değil. Eee, Osmanlı'da da
ı Mahmut yapıyordu. Doğru. Geçelim diğer
soruya. Aşağı artıda bazı ülkeler
numarandırak gösterilmiştir. Bu
ülkelerden hangisinin nüfus miktarının
fazla olması kalkınma hızının düşük
olmasına neden olmuştur? Amerika'da
nüfus miktarı fazla değildir gençler.
Nüfus miktarı fazladır. Miktar olarak,
milyon kişi olarak. Ama nüfus artış hızı
fazla değildir. Kalkınma hızı
Amerika'nın nüfus artış hızından daha
yüksektir. Asıl problem kalkınma hızının
nüfus artış hızından düşük olduğunda
yaşanıyor. Rusya'nın kalkınma hızı nüfus
artış hızından daha yüksektir. Fransa
işaretlenmiş burada. Fransa'nın kalkınma
hızı yüksektir. Avustralya gelişmiştir.
Kalkınma hızı yüksektir. Ama Nijerya
kalkınma hızı düşüktür. Nüfus artış hızı
daha yüksek. Problem burada ortaya
çıkıyor. Nüfus artış hızının kalkınma
hızından daha fazla olduğu yerlerde
ortaya çıkıyor problem. Bunla Nijerya
buradaki problem yaşayacak ülke. Geçelim
diğer soruya. 20. yüzyıl öncesi nüfus
sayımlarının amacı aşağıdakilerden
hangisidir? Eskiden neden nüfus
sayımları yapılıyordu? Vergi ve asker
için. Askeri alınanlarının vergi
yükümlülükleri sayısının belirlemek.
Cevap A. Kolay bir soruydu. Direkt net
bilgi olduğu için geçelim diğer soruya.
Şimdi asıl soru bu tarz sorular. Bu tarz
soruları yorumlamak değerli. Bu tarz
soruları bize grafik okuma becerisi
olarak soruyorlar nüfusta. O yüzden soru
gelecekse bu konudan böyle grafik
gelecek. Grafik evilere göre bu
ülkelerle ilgili aşağıdaki ifadelerden
hangisi yanlıştır? Bakın şu mor şehir,
şu kır. Buna göre yorumlayalım. K'nın
şehir nüfus oranı M'nin kır nüfus
oranından azdır. Bakacağız. K'yı
bulacağız. Şehir nüfus oranı 54'müş.
M'nin şehir nüfusu. Ha, M'nin kır
nüfusunu soruyor. M'nin kır nüfusu 77.
K'nın şehir nüfusu 54. 77'den az mı 54?
Evet. O da azdır diyor zaten. O zaman
doğru böyle grafik okumayı öğrenmen
lazım. Bu kadar basittir soru. Şehir
nüfus miktarı en fazla olan L ülkesidir.
Bak şehir nüfus miktarı diyor bize.
Burada ne vermiş? Oran vermiş. Grafikte
herhangi bir şekilde miktarla alakalı
bir şey var mı? Miktarla alakalı bir şey
yok grafikte. Bakın bize şöyle deseydi.
Şehir nüfus oranı en fazla olan L''dir
deseydi. Şehir nüfus en fazla olan L.
Evet. Ama şehir nüfus oranı en fazla
olan şehir nüfus miktarını ben bilemem
ki. Miktarını bilemediğim için yorum
yapamam. Mesela bakın K'nın nüfusu 100
milyonluk bir şehir olsun. L''nin nüfusu
100 kişi olsun. Şimdi 100 kişinin %86'sı
86 kişi yapar ama 100 milyon kişinin
100.000 kişinin %54'ü 54.000 kişi yapar.
Oransal olarak %54 86'dan daha düşük ama
bakın 54.000 kişi diyoruz. Ha demek ki
nüfus miktarını bilmeden oranlara
bakarak miktar yorumu yapamam ben. O
yüzden B şıkkı yanlış. Direkt
diğerlerini de yorumlayalım. Yorumlamayı
öğren. M'nin şehir nüfus oranı bak oranı
diyor. Görüyor musun? Bak bak. M'nin
M'nin şehir nüfus oranı 23. Tamam.
L''nin kır nüfus oranından L''nin kır
nüfus oranı 14. Tamam. Fazladır. Evet.
23. 14'ten fazladır. Doğru. Şehirleşme
oranı en fazla olan L ülkesidir.
Bakıyorum. Şehrin en fazla olduğu L
doğru. K'daki şehirleşme oranı. K'daki
şehirleşme 54. M'den fazladır. M de 23.
Evet. 54 23'ten fazladır. Doğru. Yani
cevabımız B. Gençler bu soruda ne
öğrendin? Grafik sana oran olarak
verildiyse miktar yorumu yapamaz.
Geçelim diğer soruya. Ama bakın şöyle
şurada parantez içinde derse ki buradaki
ülkenin nüfusu işte bütün ülkelerin
nüfusunu verse bize 1 milyondur
100.000'dir bindir dese sen şimdi
ülkenin nüfusunu bildiğin için oranını
belirlersin. Ülkenin nüfusu 1 milyonsa
bunun %54'ü 540.000 yapar dersin. Ama
nüfus miktarını verirse sana, nüfus
miktarını vermezse oran grafiğine
bakarak miktar yorumu yapmayacaksın.
Öğretmenin yazılı sınavda sınavında
ortalama yaşam süresi ülkelerin
sağlıktaki seviyeleriyle doğrudan
ilişkili ve gelişmişliğin
göstergelerinden biridir. Bu tarz
ülkelere beş ülke örneği yazınız
sorusuna Çiğdem'in verdiği cevapta
aşağıdaki ülkeler yer almaktadır. Çiğdem
her ülkenin 2 puanı olduğu bu sorudan 8
puan almıştır. Buna göre Çiğdem bu
ülkelerin hangisine yanlışlık yapmıştır?
Japonya gelişmiş, ABD gelişmiş,
Hollanda, Almanya gelişmiş, Bangladeş
gelişmemiştir. Ortalama yaşam süresi
düşüktür. Bak bu yorumu, bu soruyu böyle
yapıyorsun. Çok kolay bir soru. Geçelim
diğer soruya. Aşağı grafikte bazı
ülkeler ve dünyadaki doğumda beklenen
ortalama yaşam süreleri verilmiştir.
Grafiğe göre numaralımış ülkelerin
hangisinde verilenler olabilir?
Aşağıdakil hangisinde verilenler
olabilir? Bakın birinci ülke %83.
Ortalama yaşam süresi çok yüksek. O
zaman bu gelişmiş olacak. 2'ye bakın.
Ortalama yaşam süresi dünyanın altında.
O zaman bu gelişmemiş. Yani burası
Somali gibi gelişmemiş olacak. Burası
Almanya gibi gelişmiş ülke olacak.
İspanya çat gelişmiş gelişmemiş. O zaman
cevap A. İngiltere gelişmiş, gelişmiş
olmaz. Gelişmemiş gelişmemiş. Gelişmekte
olan diyelim olmaz. Gelişmemiş gelişmiş
olmaz. Gelişmiş gelişmiş olmaz. Cevap A.
Geçelim diğer soruya. Bir ülkede
göçlerin etkisiyle meydana gelen nüfus
artışı doğumlarla olan nüfus artışından
fazlaysa bu ülkede gerçek nüfus artışı
daha fazladır. Yani bir ülke göç
alıyorsa orada gerçek nüfus artışı
vardır. Peki hangi ülkeler göç alır? ABD
gibi, Fransa gibi ülkeler göç alır.
Portekiz de göç alır. Ama bunlar
arasında en fazla olanı, en fazla göç
alanı hangisidir? ABD ve Fransa'dır. O
zaman cevabımız en fazla gerçek göç,
gerçek nüfus artışı olan bu doğrultuda
ABD ve Fransa olur. Geçelim diğer
soruya. Aşağıdakilerden hangisi bir
ülkenin kalkınmasına olumlu katkıda
bulunur? Yaşam standartlarının düşük
olması. Olumsuz bir şey bu. Yaşam
standardı düşük. Genç nüfus oranının
fazla olması. Genç nüfus oranının çok
fazla olması. Olumlu katkıları da var
ama olumsuz katkıları da fazla. Bağımlı
nüfus sonuçta genç nüfus. Gelişmemiş
ülkenin özelliği. Aktif nüfusun çok daha
çok hizmet sektöründe çalışması. Bir
ülkede aktif nüfus hizmet sektöründe
çalışıyorsa o ülke gelişmiş bir ülkeydi,
değil mi? O yüzden cevabımız C. Bebek
ölüm oranı yüksekse gelişmemiştir.
Ortalama yaşam süresi kısaysa
gelişmemiştir. Cevap C. Geçelim diğer
soruya. Aşağı grafikte üç farklı ülke
nüfusunun yaş gruplarına dağılıma
oranları gösterilmiştir. Bakın 65 yaş.
Görüyor musunuz? 65 yaşın en fazla
olduğu ülke burası. He o zaman burası
gelişmiş bir ülke. Almanya. Somutluyorum
bak. Sonra 14. Çocuklara bakıyorum.
Çocukların en fazla olduğu ülke burası.
O zaman burası gelişmemiş ülke. Yani
Somali. Burası da orta. Bunların
ikisinin de ortası. Bakalım şimdi
hangisi yanlıştır? 014 yaş grubu en
fazla L ülkesindedir. Evet. Bakın 014 en
fazla Somali'de. Doğru. Yaşlı nüfus
oranı en fazla M'dedir. M'de bulmuştuk
bunu zaten en başta. Doğru. 1564 yaş
grubu üç ülkede de birbirine yakındır.
Bakın yakın değil mi? Doğru. Gelişmişlik
seviyesi en yüksek olan S'dir.
Gelişmişlik seviyesi en yüksek olan
M'dir. Neden? Çünkü yaşlı nüfusu en
fazla olan burası. Gelişmişlik seviyesi
en düşük olan neresidir? Somali'dir. En
fazla çocuk burada çünkü. Cevap D.
Geçelim diğer soruya. Aşağıda bir
ülkedeki çalışanların ekonomik faaliyet
kollarına dağılım oranları
gösterilmiştir. Hizmet %71. Tarımda
çalışan çok az. He burası Almanya gibi
gelişmiş bir ülke. Somutladım. Şimdi
çözmek çok kolay. Bak bu ülkeyle ilgili
ifadelerin hangileri doğrudur?
Somutlarsanız çözmek çok kolaydır. Bak
somutlama da bir kodlamadır. Bu arada şu
an ben size kodlamayı öğretiyorum.
Somutlararak nasıl kodlayacağınızı
öğrendim. Kiş başına şu milli geliri
yüksek midir Almanya'da? Evet. Yaşlı
nüfus oranı evet Almanya'da yüksektir.
Yaşlıdır insanlar. Ortalama yaşam süresi
kısa değil uzundur Almanya'da. Bu
yanlış. Almanya'da insanlar uzun yaşar.
Sağlık imkanları yüksek. 1 ve 2 C. Evet,
testimizi de bitirdik. Evet, bu konunun
da testi bitti gençler. Burada önemli
öğrenmemiz gereken değerli konular
vardı. Lütfen ezber yapmayın. O
maddeleri ezberlemeyin. Sadece nasıl
yorum yapacağını öğrendin. Testlerde
yorum yapmayı biliyorsun. Bitti gitti.
Dönüp arkana bir daha bakm gerek yok. Bu
konularda diyoruz ve ne diyoruz?
Kömürden elmasa dönüşebilmeniz
dileğiyle.